foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday February 7th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
how smart do you want your home to be
there are a growing number of so-called
Smart Home Appliances that you can buy
these days Internet connected washing
machines refrigerators ovens and more
but according to their makers many
customers who buy these smart devices
don't have them synced up to their home
Wi-Fi
that's actually something of a challenge
for the companies that make them so
what's happening here and why is the
appliance industry betting on Smart
Homes anyway
with me to discuss this is wsjcio
Journal reporter Isabelle buscat hi
Isabelle thanks for being here yeah
thanks for having me Zoe so let's just
start off with some Basics around smart
appliances when did they take off and
what features differentiate them from
say a traditional Appliance yeah this
was a trend that really started gaining
Traction in 2014 and the idea from the
appliance manufacturers was that when
you bought an oven or a washing machine
or a dishwasher you would take that
Appliance home and you would connect it
to your home's Wi-Fi network and once
that device is connected there are a
range of different features that it
would offer to you so for example smart
appliances are available for
over-the-air updates meaning companies
can update them with software patches
and give them new features if it's an
oven for example it might get an air
frying thing feature and that's just
your existing Appliance getting updated
without you having to go purchase more
updated model you could interact with
them via an app like a Roomba and the
whole home would just cater to your
needs a little bit more okay so it can
get software updates I can I don't know
maybe turn it on and off from my
smartphone but what are the companies
saying about how many people are
actually connecting these devices to
their home's Wi-Fi and I guess why
aren't more people connecting them to
the internet the important thing to
recognize about a smart Appliance is
that it can't really be smart unless it
is connected to your home's Wi-Fi
network and there are a number of
reasons why people might choose not to
connect it privacy reasons but what's
also really common is that people do
have it connected either they do it
themselves or whoever's installing the
machine does it when they first buy it
but then over the course of time it's
really easy for these devices to get
disconnected so if you change your Wi-Fi
password for example if the Wi-Fi fi
goes out for a moment if you get a new
provider if you get a new router all
these things can result in the device
being disconnected even say you have
your washing machine in a part of the
house like your basement that's far from
your router and so the signal is weak
and it might go out for an instant all
those things can result in the device
getting disconnected and the reality is
for a lot of people they're just not
going to bother to take the time to kind
of note that and then reconnect it and
so what do the big makers of these smart
devices say about how many of of these
smart appliances are actually connected
to the Wi-Fi yeah so for LG they say
it's less than half their devices end up
staying connected once they're in
consumers homes and for Whirlpool they
say it's more than half but declined to
get more specific than that why do these
companies care if their devices are
connected or not I mean presumably
they've already sold the dishwasher the
washing machine so you know to them what
does it matter yeah the stakes are
actually really high for them and in
terms of the pressure to find new lines
of Revenue traditionally these Appliance
makers their business bottles would
essentially be based around these kind
of one-time purchases so you go out and
you buy a dishwasher and maybe you don't
buy another one for 10 or 15 years but
what they really are trying to do and
what they really need to do now is sort
of reinvent that relationship with the
customer so that it's more ongoing and
part of that is that when people have
their appliances connected they can
constantly be getting data about how
people are using those devices in their
homes how often what types of things
they're using them for and then they can
use that data to sell them on new
products and services so as an example
LG was monitoring the amount of water
that was passing through water filters
and people's refrigerators and based on
that data it was able to Ping people
when it was time for them to buy a new
water filter and based on rolling out
that feature they were able to see an
increased amount of sales from water
filters from people that had those
refrigerators connected compared to
people who didn't so that's the model
they're aspiring to but again it's
really only something that works if the
customer plays along Isabel you
mentioned that the stakes are high for
these companies I mean how high are we
talking what issues are they up against
the stakes are definitely really high
the manufacturing sector is definitely
hurting right now there's weakening
consumer demand rise in cost of
materials rise in cost of energy last
year during the third quarter Whirlpool
cut production by 35 to shrink
inventories the bottom line is that
these initiatives and finding new lines
of revenue from these smart features are
a really really big priority for them
right now so what are these companies
like LG like Whirlpool doing to fix the
connection rate yeah there's a few
different way ways they're approaching
that problem one is just better
awareness so on the shop floor they'll
educate customers better about the kinds
of benefits they get from connecting and
how they can do that they're working
through the delivery agents who install
the appliances to make sure that's
definitely happening at the point of
installation there's also some work they
can do on the software side to manage
issues like how do you make it
automatically reconnect if it
disconnects because of a brief Wi-Fi
outage and then on the hardware side
they can also work to ensure that these
appliances have stronger antennas so
that again if they end up in a part of
the house that has weaker signal they
can still remain connected alright
that's our reporter Isabel busquet
thanks for joining us Isabel thanks so
much for having me and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]